The New York Times just published this article about who will care for kinless seniors
Those are seniors who do not have a living spouse or children
to take care of them in their older age
This is actually a really big problem
I see it all the time in the hospital
and is only expected to grow as time goes on
People who are in older age cannot take care of themselves in their home
don't have a spouse
don't have children to take care of them
We often times have to send them to a nursing home to live
frequently for the rest of their lives
And it's more common now than it previously was
because baby boomers are more likely than the generation before them
to be unmarried and not have children
And it's going to grow and grow even more
especially as people in my generation decide not to get married
and decide not to have children
Now typically
for these people who when they get older
don't have a family member to take care of them
you really either have to pay out of pocket to hire private caregivers
which is extremely expensive
Or one other option that a lot of people are taking is buying long term care insurance
so that they can get help in paying for a private caregiver to live in their home
so that they can age in place and stay where they are
instead of having to go to a Nursing home
But these options to have caregivers come to your home
is only available to people who have some means
For poor and even middle class seniors
this really isn't a possibility
So as a society
this is something that we really need to think about
We need to create policies that will incentivize
programs that can help senior stay in their home
help people age in place
Because it's really sad to see when people are isolated in their older age
don't have any sort of caregiver support at home
and are essentially forced to live in a nursing home
I think when most people think about how they wanna age
that's not it